[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
April 25th I'm Dion rabone from The Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
having made it through the lockdowns and
health scares the past few years a
number of older Americans are saying no
to retirement and not just for right now
some say they want to keep on working
until they literally can't work anymore
joining me is Demetria Gallegos from wsj
General reports so Demetria no days off
has become a popular slogan for Hustlers
trying to make it in competitive
Industries like entertainment Tech and
business but you talk to some folks who
are really taking that adage to a new
level tell me about the never retire
movement or hashtag never retire Dion we
reached out to wsj readers with the
question about whether they have chosen
to work past retirement age and if so
why what inspires them and what kind of
choices were they looking at and we got
an overwhelming response we had several
hundred people respond to us with an
intention never to retire for a wide
variety of reasons but most of those
reasons are that they enjoy what they're
doing they're having the time of their
life they see retirement as a long Abyss
unless they have a purpose and intent
and in many cases these people have
achieved Mastery in their careers
they've achieved salary levels that they
never dreamed of and they're wondering
why in the world would they walk away
from that and you spoke with more than a
dozen people for this story who were
approaching retirement age or what we
typically think of as the retirement age
what stuck out most about the collection
the conversations that you had I think
what stuck out most was how smart these
people are at adapting their work lives
to a different chapter in their own
personal lives and energy levels for
example there's the woman in Texas who
walked away from a partnership at a law
firm to start her own Enterprise and to
take on just the client she's interested
in helping and finds it much more
rewarding and fulfilling and also has a
great degree of flexibility and the
ability to work remotely as they all do
now as many of these seniors responded
that was a big Advantage the wear and
tear factor for a commuting life is no
longer as big an obstacle for them and
you did a lot of these interviews did
you believe all of them did they all
seem like they were really going to put
off retirement as long as possible or
were there a couple people you talked to
who are like nah this person is going to
be out on a lake in two years stops well
most of the people we spoke to were 60
and older and they are already in that
phase they are fulfilling that promise
to keep working many of them were
inspired by examples around them their
parents their mentors their professors
who kept working and showed a lot of
benefits especially cognitive and
physical benefits for staying in the
workplace in other cases they were
dissuaded from retirement by examples
around them from their own families or
friends who people who stepped away from
the workplace and then just could not
necessarily find something new to latch
onto and did not necessarily thrive in
their retirement years so in one of the
cases I spoke to a woman who had stepped
out of her career earlier in order to
raise kids and then later to serve as a
caregiver for a family member has just
now returned at almost age 60 and she's
raring to go she wants to make up for
lost time she doesn't see an end to this
current trajectory she's honest but she
did just buy a lake cabin and is
planning to continue her career from
that setting many of the people you
interviewed said they don't want to stop
working like you said because they enjoy
what they do they're invigorated but for
some the plan not to retire seems based
more in fear or expectations for
negative outcomes can you tell me a
little about that yes we did include
people who feels the stock market is too
volatile for example for them to feel
comfortable financially without an
income a couple people felt they
wouldn't have the same Health Care
choices as retirees that they would as
long as they stayed in the workforce in
other cases they simply could not fathom
with our expanded lifespans these days
what they would do with their time over
the course of decades and we had seen a
decline over on the number of people
over 55 who are staying in the workforce
but this trend kind of flies in the face
of that were there people who they'd
talk to some folks who said no you
should be retiring and they were like
absolutely not not for me or did most of
the people in their lives seem to be
supportive of this decision I was
touched to hear an example of a doctor
in Colorado who continues to work
because he is a widower and he does not
have a wife with whom he wants to spend
those retirement years at this point
there's certainly so many personal
factors I do think that a couple are
trying to set examples for their
children one person mentioned that their
father-in-law at 90 is still working and
so he doesn't feel like he can step away
yet just to save face based on your
reporting does it seem like the idea of
what retirement is is changing I think
while our idea of retirement continues
to evolve our idea of the work life also
changes especially after pandemic when
you have technology allowing folks to
work well past their original plans
because their setting is now flexible I
feel as though people are now Feathering
these two phases in their life together
in a potentially much more fulfilling
way one that is very financially
sustaining as well as in terms of their
energy and their sense of purpose and
what does this say about what retirement
looks like I I think one of the
strongest Impressions I got from this
group is that they imagine their
retirement years or will last for quite
a while they are expecting to live much
longer than their parents and
grandparents did they want to make sure
this is a productive time in their life
and not just a time for sitting on the
sofa watching TV and having talked to
all these people who are near what we
tend to think of as retirement age but
are saying very clearly that they don't
plan to retire what did it make you
think about for your own plans for your
golden years I I think all of these
folks reminded me that I should continue
to pay attention to what it is that I
enjoy about my work life and to try to
figure out whether there's a way to
adapt into that for example one person
is an investigative attorney who
specializes in finding missing people he
loves puzzles he loves cryptograms but
he says he has paid to do this in real
life now in a way that is incredibly
fulfilling to him we have others who
have figured out that it's the
intellectual exercise of learning itself
that they love about their work lives
and they don't necessarily feel that
they could accomplish all of that
without a structured workplace program
my idea is that while I imagine I might
be very successful at being retired in
terms of generally being able to
entertain myself I want to keep learning
and I want to be reminding myself that
my brain is still capable of absorbing
new information at any age all right so
you and me hashtag never retire hashtag
never retire Dion love it alright that
was Wall Street Journal editor dimetria
Gallegos thank you very much for being
with us and that's your money briefing
I'm Dion rabone for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
thank you